hablemos sobre las gráficas de posición
contra tiempo y si ustedes ya las han
visto sabrán que son un poco curiosas
pero a los físicos y a los maestros les
encantan aparecen siempre en muchos de
los exámenes porque es que les gusta
tanto a muchas personas pues porque
puedes tener muchísima información en
ellas mucha información acerca del
movimiento de un objeto en una pequeña
gráfica aquí se especifica el movimiento
de un objeto ni siquiera tenemos que
escribir alguna ecuación puede
escribirlo con muchas palabras todo está
aquí y esto es muy práctico veamos cómo
podemos trabajar con ellas esta gráfica
representa el movimiento de un objeto y
en lugar de decir un objeto en general
vamos a hacerlo específico y vamos a
decir que es el movimiento de esta
tortuga que tiene un cohete a la espalda
y como no queremos preocupar a nadie
vamos a ponerle un casco a esta tortuga
un casco rosa que le queda muy bien
ahora nuestra tortuga está segura para
volar en cohete
esta tortuga se está moviendo y esta
gráfica representa el movimiento de esta
tortuga en particular un error que
muchas personas cometen es pensar que
esto es el movimiento tal cual del
objeto que la forma de esta gráfica es
la forma del movimiento del objeto en el
espacio así que quizás la tortuga fue
hacia adelante luego se fue hacia abajo
y luego despegó hacia arriba pero esto
no se acerca para nada a la realidad
para saber lo que dice esta gráfica
permíteme poner un eje horizontal aquí
este eje va a representar la posición
horizontal de la tortuga le llamamos x
iba a estar medida en metros y lo hago
así porque si se fijan acá en esta
gráfica el eje vertical es la posición
horizontal es la posición horizontal de
mi tortuga esto es lo que estamos
graficando significa que si tenemos
nuestra tortuga en un punto por acá en x
igual a 2
la gráfica debe representar cuando se
encuentra la tortuga en esta posición
cuando x es igual a 2 más o menos como a
los 2.4 segundos es cuando se encuentra
la tortuga
esta posición analicemos esta gráfica
para conocer qué es lo que hizo esta
tortuga no es que se haya ido hacia
adelante hacia abajo y hacia arriba
cuando tenemos de igual a cero vamos
hacia arriba y cuando t es igual a cero
el valor de esta gráfica es 3 y el valor
de esta gráfica representa la posición
horizontal cuando t es igual a 0 la
tortuga se encuentra a los 3 metros
vamos a ponerla por acá
ahora qué sucede pues cuando t es igual
a un segundo hacemos lo mismo
subimos nos encontramos con la gráfica y
vemos que el valor que tiene siguen
siendo los tres metros
nuevamente subimos tocamos la gráfica y
nos vamos hacia la izquierda para ver
cuál es el valor que tiene y resulta que
la tortuga sigue en los tres metros a
los dos segundos subimos llegamos a la
gráfica nos vamos a la izquierda y la
tortuga sigue en los tres metros está
muy raro esta tortuga no se está
moviendo durante los primeros dos
segundos la tortuga permanece aquí por
lo que tenemos aquí una línea recta una
línea horizontal en una gráfica de
posición contra tiempo indica que no se
mueve probablemente esta tortuga está
tratando de darse cuenta de qué es lo
que está pasando con su cohete bueno la
tortuga cuando t es igual a 4 segundos
está a menos 5 metros está hasta aquí
entre los dos segundos y los 4 segundos
la tortuga se fue en reversa lo que está
muy raro seguramente no se dio cuenta
que metió reversa ay qué tortuga así que
llegó hasta acá y después que sucedió
después la tortuga se movió hacia
adelante llegó de nuevo a cero metros y
regresó hasta los tres metros esto es lo
que hizo la tortuga y esto es lo que
representa esta gráfica y así es como la
leemos pero hay más información que solo
esto aquí una de las cosas que tenemos
aquí es el desplazamiento de la tortuga
vamos a representarlo con delta x
recordemos que el desplazamiento es la
posición final menos la posición inicial
podemos encontrar el desplazamiento
entre dos tiempos diferentes en la
gráfica para simplificar los cálculos
digamos que vamos a encontrar el
desplazamiento total pero podría igual
encontrarlo entre 0 y 4 segundos pero
vamos a calcularlo desde 0 hasta 10 pues
es la posición de la tortuga a los 10
segundos ella está en los 3 metros
- y como estamos considerando todo el
tiempo la posición que tenía cuando el
tiempo era igual a 0 y aquí entre igual
a 0 estaba a 3 metros significa que el
desplazamiento total fue de 0 lo cual
tiene sentido porque esta tortuga se
encontraba en los 3 metros retrocedió
hasta los -5 bueno de hecho comenzó en
los 3 metros se quedó por ahí un par de
segundos luego se fue hacia atrás hasta
-5 y después regresó hasta 3 y terminó
en el mismo lugar en el que comenzó así
que no hubo desplazamiento total que
otra cosa podemos encontrar pues la
distancia total recuerden que la
distancia es la suma de cada uno de los
movimientos que hizo la tortuga en este
punto la distancia fue de 0 esta fue la
parte extraña y mejor no lo mencionamos
para no lastimar sus sentimientos así
que aquí tenemos 0 metros más entre 2
segundos y 4 segundos
la tortuga pasó de 35 y la distancia que
viajo es de 8 metros
será esto negativo no la distancia
siempre va a ser positiva la longitud de
estos movimientos siempre va a ser
positiva la tortuga estaba en 3 luego
fue hasta 5 por lo que la distancia
total fue de 8 en este segmento más la
distancia que recorrió entre los 4
segundos y los 10 segundos pasó de menos
5 metros hasta 3 metros 1 que viajó
otros 8 metros por lo que la distancia
total fue de 16 metros y esto podemos
hacerlo para cualquier par de puntos en
la gráfica que más podemos encontrar
aquí pues la velocidad promedio a veces
la representamos como una uve con una
barra arriba o con la abreviatura de
promedio recordemos que la velocidad es
el desplazamiento entre el tiempo y
encontremos los valores totales aquí la
velocidad promedio total es el
desplazamiento total que ya lo tenemos
aquí vimos que es cero para todo el
tiempo de la gráfica vimos que es cero
en todo el viaje cero metros dividido
entre bueno realmente no importa entre
que lo dividamos porque el resultado va
a ser cero
pero aquí el tiempo fueron diez segundos
que tardó el desplazamiento total por lo
que aquí no tenemos una velocidad
promedia la velocidad promedio para todo
el tiempo fue de cero metros por segundo
cuál fue la rapidez promedio a veces se
encuentran esto representado como una s
con una barra arriba o con la
abreviación de promedio con los físicos
nunca sabemos qué es lo que van a
decidir usar la rapidez promedio es
igual a la distancia entre el tiempo y
nuevamente vamos a tratar de encontrar
la rapidez promedio total para todo el
rango de tiempo de aquí y no es difícil
ya encontramos cuál es la distancia
total fueron 16 metros 16 metros
dividido entre el tiempo total que fue
de 10 segundos
así que la tortuga tuvo una rapidez
promedio total de 1.6 metros por segundo
quizás esto hubiera sido un poco más
grande si no hubiera tenido esa
dificultad técnica al inicio podemos
calcular aún más cosas aquí podemos
encontrar la velocidad instantánea que
la pueden encontrar como uve y la
abreviación de instantánea o también se
la pueden encontrar como uve ya que es a
esto a lo que nos referimos cuando
hablamos de velocidad el valor
instantánea y esto aquí es igual aquí
está la idea principal y quizás es la
idea más importante en todo este vídeo
para encontrar la velocidad instantánea
cuando tenemos una gráfica de posición
contra tiempo nos vamos a fijar en la
pendiente resulta que la pendiente de
una gráfica de posición contra el tiempo
es la velocidad en esa dirección
tenemos una gráfica de posición
horizontal contra el tiempo por lo que
este pendiente nos va a dar la velocidad
en la dirección horizontal y no sólo eso
si encontramos la pendiente promedio
vamos a encontrar la velocidad
instantánea promedio si encuentro la
pendiente
instantánea tendré la velocidad
instantánea cómo hago esto en general si
tenemos una gráfica con curvas tendremos
que usar cálculo para encontrar la
pendiente instantánea pero tenemos
suerte todas las líneas de nuestra
gráfica son líneas rectas lo que
significa es que la pendiente promedio
en cualquier par de puntos de una de
estas líneas de la gráfica va a ser
igual a la pendiente instantánea en
cualquier punto de esa línea vamos a
hacer esto específico digamos que
queremos conocer la velocidad
instantánea a los 3 segundos cómo
hacemos esto tenemos que ver qué
significa esto la velocidad instantánea
significa que tenemos que encontrar la
pendiente en este momento ubico en mi
gráfica el número 3 y voy a donde está
la gráfica y quiero encontrar la
pendiente instantánea justo aquí como
hago esto bueno les comenté que la clave
aquí es la pendiente promedio entre
cualquier par de puntos de esta línea
puedo elegir estos dos puntos si yo
quiero la pendiente promedio entre esto
puntos va a ser igual a la pendiente
instantánea en cualquier punto de esta
misma línea porque vean una pendiente no
está cambiando en ninguna parte de esta
línea la pendiente permanece constante y
si quieren encontrar el promedio de
muchas cantidades que son iguales
tendremos el mismo valor como promedio y
esta fue una forma complicada de decir
que si por ejemplo quiero sacar el
promedio de 8 8 8 y 8 pues el promedio
de esto va a hacer 8 también que es
igual a cualquiera de estos valores por
lo que si tenemos una gráfica con una
línea recta están de suerte porque no
van a necesitar cálculo podrán encontrar
la pendiente instantánea en cualquier
punto al encontrar la pendiente promedio
entre cualquier par de puntos puede
elegir estos dos por qué pues porque sé
exactamente en dónde se encuentran esta
es 2,3
y este es 4,5 y ustedes se pueden
preguntar por qué es que la velocidad es
igual a la pendiente recuerden de las
clases de matemáticas que la pendiente
es igual al desplazamiento vertical
entre el desplazamiento horizontal y
seguramente lo vieron de esta forma de 2
menos de 1 entre x 2 - x 1 así es como
solíamos verlo en matemáticas y lo vimos
así porque en matemáticas las gráficas
normalmente tienen el eje vertical como
ye y el eje horizontal como x pero esta
es una gráfica de física nuestro eje
horizontal no es x este y nuestro eje
vertical es el que llamamos x así que en
esta gráfica de física aquí el
desplazamiento vertical es este eje x 2
- x 1 y el desplazamiento horizontal
este 2 - de 1 como hacemos esto bueno
este es el punto 2 y este es el punto 1
cómo determinamos cuál es el punto 2 y
cuál es el punto 1 pues el punto más
alejado en el tiempo es el que elegimos
como el punto 2 así que en 4 segundos y
menos 5 metros tenemos nuestro punto 2 x
2 va a ser menos 5 ya que esto es lo que
tenemos en mi punto 2 - x 1 en el punto
1 nuestro
x estrés no es 4 recuerden que este es
el tiempo no la posición la posición
horizontal del punto 1 es 3 metros lo
ponemos negativo porque la fórmula
tenemos son menos lo dividimos entre
tiempo 2 que es 4 segundos menos tiempo
1 que es de 2 segundos y si resolvemos
esto nos va a quedar menos 8 metros
entre dos segundos que nos da menos 4
metros por segundo esta es la velocidad
instantánea en los 3 segundos es
negativo porque la tortuga iba hacia
atrás
recuerden que esto fue cuando puso la
reversa sin darse cuenta y se fue hacia
atrás hasta el menos 5 metros es
negativo y 4 porque estuvo avanzando 4
metros cada segundo recorrió 8 metros en
dos segundos lo que significa que iba a
4 metros por segundo en promedio y como
esta es una línea recta esta es la tasa
de su velocidad en cualquier momento en
cualquier punto de esta línea
y esto también sería si quisiéramos
encontrar la velocidad instantánea a los
12 en 2.4 segundos no se preocupen este
valor es el mismo en toda esta recta
menos 4 metros por segundo en toda esta
línea y podemos encontrar una cosa más
digamos que nos preguntan cuál es la
rapidez instantánea en cierto punto
puede ser ese con la abreviatura de
instantáneo o simplemente la s que es lo
que significa la rapidez va a ser igual
al valor absoluto de la velocidad
instantánea y aquí tengo que hacer una
suposición esto es algo muy sutil si lo
único que nos dan es una gráfica de
posición horizontal no sabremos nada de
la posición vertical cuando esta tortuga
iba hacia atrás y hacia adelante también
puedo ir hacia arriba y hacia abajo si
la posición horizontal hubiera sido la
misma todo el trayecto esto luciría
igual sin importar si la tortuga hubiera
volado hacia arriba o hacia abajo
tenemos que tener cuidado en comprender
que esta es la velocidad pero en el eje
horizontal
vamos a suponer que esta tortuga
solamente se estaba moviendo
horizontalmente no tuvo ningún
movimiento vertical todavía no está
lista para esto así que la rapidez es
simplemente el valor absoluto de la
velocidad instantánea si es el único
componente de la velocidad entonces
puedo calcular esto muy fácilmente
aunque bueno aquí tengo que indicar en
qué momento del tiempo es una rapidez
instantánea y esta rapidez instantánea
tiene que ser en un momento dado la
rapidez instantánea aquí fue de 0 y la
velocidad instantánea en este punto cuál
sería puede ser el valor absoluto de
esto 4 metros por segundo positivo y
esta es la rapidez instantánea a los 3
segundos o en cualquier momento entre
los 2 y los 4 segundos vaya así que fue
mucho ya les había dicho que esta
gráfica contiene mucha información vamos
a repasar rápidamente todo lo que vimos
el valor de la posición horizontal
contra el tiempo nos da la posición
horizontal varias sorpresas la posición
en una gráfica de posición horizontal
contra el tiempo
velocidad en la dirección x la pendiente
promedio nos da la velocidad promedio la
pendiente instantánea nos da la
velocidad instantánea y si tenemos una
línea recta sin ninguna curva estas dos
van a ser iguales estas nos van a ser
iguales en cualquier línea dada en este
caso no son iguales porque yo calculé el
promedio en todo el tiempo es la
velocidad promedio en todo el tiempo y
está pendiente no está cambiando aquí
tengo el promedio de todo esto y es por
eso que estos dos valores no son iguales
si yo me restringieran a un valor
promedio en una parte de la línea que no
tenga cambio en la pendiente este sería
igual a la velocidad instantánea en ese
punto y la rapidez instantánea es la
magnitud de la velocidad instantánea
suponiendo que tenemos movimiento en una
sola dirección